comment donc nous atterrissons bientôt
d'allemagne
j'ai un problème j'ai un problème j'ai
descendu et j'ai descendu avec le train
comment ça le train de vie enfin madame
mais qu'est ce que vous racontez chetrat
coincé c'est tout sinon ça que vous avez
une grande et des mains vous en prie
même c'est d'un gouffre du train
d'atterrissage train d'atterrissage il
sort pas mal mais cavani en fin de
compte nous sommes en avion si nous
ratons ce travail jean prendra l'eau et
doit bien le train-train guérissant
jusque sur les éleveurs qui se déploie
comme ça et puis c'est ce sur quoi on
atterrira temps quand je crois que
savait la piscine ou la piste c'est par
terre pour qu'on se pose par terre il
faut que l'avion est en alerte orange ou
qui sont en dessous de l'appareil et ne
sortent pas mal mais veulent pas sortir
pour manger la notice et belges viennent
faire tout ça mais ça ne marche pas à
appuyer sur le bouton et qui peuvent
décompresser le 4,36 desserrer le 16 aux
tirs et la manade 26 le clignotant rouge
clignote voilà voilà
hélas cet enfant simplement ça marche
pas le commandant de marche non ça mais
ça ne marche pas mais monsieur le train
d'atterrissage d'un avion ça sort
toujours mon fils et moi donc s'il vous
plaît
alors n'allez pas me dire qu'avec celle
du temps de rien faire parce que c'est
celui là ça c'est le testing à côté vous
avez peut-être c'est lent et pour ceux
qui t'ont sa profondeur inouïe ce qu'ils
vont et celui là ça c'est le grito ce
dont tu fais ça c'est l'allume-cigare
madame mais à l'oreille travaux j'aime
sortir très vite en jeu notamment
mais madame je vous dis que je ne peux
pas regarder sa fille sur tous les
boutons ça ne clignote fort ça devrait
sortir m as a king et rsa ne clignote
pas ben écoute à leur atterrissez sur le
travail a porté ses traits pareil je
vous dis qu'on ne peut pas atterrir sans
train d'atterrissage puissent être aient
fait une heure que j'essaye de vous
l'expliquer matin et ben faut tourner en
rond jusqu'à épuisement du carburant
puis après que vous voulez on se posera
sur le point d'être comédienne que je
suis ne s'est jamais posée sur un bon
pour une fois mme uramin des choses à
proposer mais ça de 562 attendait cela
vous dire papa papa en panne a affecté
les brésil
quand je me dis qu'on tournait en rond
et d'écouté on peut pas se débarrasser
du carburant travaille aussi avec l
appuyer sur le bouton lavoyer attendait
une seule goutte à matadi arabie
saoudite a entendu on appuyés par six
ans qu'il faut la barbe et on aurait
tout de suite à force on m'a tellement
chez nous avant d'envisager tout on
pourrait peut-être essayer de parler à
cet appareil en langue étrangère
vous avez raison
ce bel oiseau semblait cependant bien du
tout pourquoi voulez-vous cette ligne
allaitantes et rochette a alors avoué
ces idées moi je ne sais pas prend des
accents solide barbezieux parce que s'il
ya là bas mais c'est tout finito ne
change rien je me disais les années ne
vous énervez pas reconnaît la langue il
va comprendre moi ce bel oiseau blanc ce
bel oiseau désir c'est la poésie
j'improvise au japon vous fais là tout
rennes pour char muhl ed l'oiseau blanc
et pour charmer la tourterelle le bel
oiseau blanc et là vous pourrez rien ne
nous on fait la taupe de rennes on est
l'oiseau blanc qu'est-ce qui fait rien
du fait pour dieu gagné cinq mais non
mais à minuit à paris on applaudit
c'était le premier c'est le premier mes
amis qui ne résiste à mada